There is something deeply unsettling about
an old house at night.
What is beautiful, if a bit worse for wear,
during the day can take on a sinister cast
once the sun goes down.
The moan of the wind outside, the creak of
the floorboards, the scraping of a branch
against a window.
Maybe one of these sounds jolts you awake
in the dead of night, eyes opening to a room
full of shadows turned twisted and eerie in
the darkness.
Of course, it’s probably nothing supernatural.
Just an old house settling, mixed with your
own paranoia.
But sometimes, every so often, it is something
more.
Sometimes you’re not as alone in an old
house as you think you are.
That’s certainly the case if you ever find
yourself staying in SCP-2696, also known as
the Haunted Victorian Mansion of Dark Peak.
In 1869, wealthy and renowned industrialist
- and scholar of the occult - Henry Percival
Rosyth built a stately home, known as Rosyth
Hall, to house him, his wife Clara, and any
children they might have in the future.
It was constructed to provide Henry with ample
space to conduct his arcane research, Clara
with a beautiful sitting room and a flower
garden to tend, and their future children
with lots of space to play and run around
as they grew.
After an uneventful year in the house, Clara
gave birth to two baby boys, named Edgar and
Miles.
For a time, the family was happy there.
Unfortunately, this happiness was to be short-lived,
as the grim specter of death soon began to
loom over Rosyth Hall.
In January of 1873, Clara was overcome with
a sudden fever and died in her bed.
This loss pushed the already eccentric Henry
over the edge, and he began making strange
changes to the house’s interior structure.
He added hallways that led to dead ends, strangely
angled floors, and twisting corners, turning
a once comfortable and lived-in home into
something unrecognizable.
In August of that same year, Henry’s children,
Edgar and Miles, also suddenly passed away,
leaving Henry alone at his estate as he continued
his descent into madness.
He kept modifying the house, expanding from
the mansion’s library and tower to the rest
of the building's rooms.
Henry’s days were spent supervising the
construction around the house, refusing to
let the workers carry on without his strict
oversight, worried that otherwise his vision
would be corrupted.
His nights were spent sleepless, as he worked
away in the tower and in the nursery on the
second floor.
No one was permitted to witness his work during
the night, but his household staff complained
of strange sounds, flashing lights, and strange
whispers.
Many were so unsettled by these sounds, and
Mr. Rosyth’s erratic behavior, that they
quit their jobs without notice.
A wise choice, given the circumstances.
As his staff dwindled, so too did Henry Rosyth’s
already fragile grip on reality.
His requests for materials became more and
more imposing.
He demanded 200 kilograms of ground stone
from Isle of Anglesey in Wales, and 37 meters
of pipes made from an amalgam of mercury and
copper, among other unconventional materials.
But Rosyth still had money to burn, and no
family to spend it on anymore, so his every
strange request was accommodated - for a time,
anyway.
In June of 1876, exhausted and unsettled by
the long hours of work, the ever increasingly
strange projects, and the unusual, supernatural
phenomena around the house, the remainder
of Rosyth’s workers quit.
He then fired all of his household staff,
with the exception of his loyal housekeeper,
and resumed his work in solitude.
Though the specifics of just what Mr Forsyth
was trying to achieve would likely have gone
to the grave with him, some of his diary entries
were recovered from the house, and they provide
a peek into his motives, and the nature of
the mansion’s anomalous activity.
After the death of his wife and children,
he became obsessed with the concept of the
“mind-made body,” the notion that having
a memory so strong that, if given the proper
energetic conditions, it could take on corporeal
form.
His theory was, if a memory is engraved permanently
in the mind, it could then take on a permanent
physical and energetic manifestation.
He began to experiment with this concept,
determined to bring back a form of his wife
and children by any means necessary.
A noble pursuit that paved the way to madness.
It is during this process that he began to
remodel the house in order to provide the
ideal energetic conditions for his memories
to be made material.
Eventually, his notes devolved into nonsense
and the pages were covered with geometric
equations and blood.
His final entry reads: “The children still
speak in her voice.
I fear I might be going mad.”
It is true that he may have been losing his
grip on sanity toward the end of his experiments,
but his work undeniably filled the house with
something.
It was not long before reports of strange
sights and sounds around the Rosyth home reached
the ears of those trained to investigate such
matters.
The house, and its anomalous nature, were
initially discovered by Jitinder Jaishankar;
an occultist and investigator employed by
the Royal Foundation for the Secure Containment
of the Paranormal - or RFSCP.
He wrote the first official report on the
house in 1876, after investigating multiple
rumors of ghostly sightings around the house.
He and his team, a married pair of ghost hunters
named The Bartons, arrived at the Rosyth home
with a sense of apprehension.
They were ushered through the door by a housekeeper,
who made the eerie promise that Henry Rosyth
would be with them shortly.
When the master of the house came to greet
them, the investigative team was shocked at
his appearance.
He was gaunt, almost skeletal, with dark,
deep-set eyes bleary from entirely too long
without sleep.
He looked as if he had aged a hundred years
in the few years since his wife’s death.
The team stayed the night in the house, experiencing
a restless and nightmare-addled sleep until
2:30 AM, when the investigative work was to
begin.
They descended down to the main hall of the
house, where a large black door was all that
stood between them and the unknown.
It opened with a bone-deep groan, as if to
warn them not to enter.
But still, they stepped inside.
Once they crossed the threshold, they were
greeted with odd angles, a garish array of
colors and materials, and bewilderingly high
ceilings.
All to Mr. Rosyth’s very demanding specifications,
of course.
He’d spared no expense in making his nonsensical
nightmare house an unsettling reality.
The Bartons presented dowsing rods, which
they used to measure spiritual activity in
the room.
At first, nothing happened, but soon the dowsing
rods began to spark viciously, and a sudden
gust of wind blew out all of the candles in
the room.
There was nothing but darkness, and a sudden
sense of a heavy presence amongst them.
The Bartons dropped to the floor, with Mrs.
Barton leaking blood from her mouth, and Dr.
Barton convulsing violently.
The presence grew stronger, and though it
did not speak it was unmistakable who it was:
it was the deceased Clara Rosyth.
Jaishankar fled the manor, dragging his unconscious
companions out as fast as he could.
Once safely away from the mansion, he immediately
contacted the RFSCP… well as quickly as
one can when communicating by telegram.
A second team was sent to investigate the
house in the following days, but when they
arrived, Henry Rosyth could not be found.
There was no sign of a struggle, no body,
he had simply vanished.
He was never seen again.
The SCP Foundation has an official record
of two separate incorporeal entities that
dwell within the walls of SCP-2696.
The first, SCP-2696-1, appears to be the ghost,
or the memory, energetic signature, whatever
you wish to call it, of Clara Rosyth.
The apparition is the one that Jitinder Jaishankar
and the Bartons encountered.
She is translucent and intangible, and most
frequently appears in the form of Clara as
a young mother, at the pinnacle of her good
health.
She has also occasionally taken on several
inhuman forms, including a wilting plumeria
bush, and a disturbing column of bone, muscle,
and flesh.
Exposure to the Clara entity has a pronounced
negative effect on anyone who comes near her.
People that come within several feet of SCP-2696-1
have reported mild visual and auditory hallucinations,
such as creeping shadows and whispering voices
chanting in foreign languages.
There have also been reports of amnesia, fainting,
seizures, bleeding from the nose, mouth, and
ears, and, in the most severe cases, dissociative
episodes that result in a complete loss of
identity.
Many of these physical side effects are thought
to be the result of the massive amounts of
radiation that have been measured being given
off by the entity.
The second entity in the house, known as SCP-2696-2,
is actually two entities that always seem
to come as a pair.
Known as 2A and 2B, these are the skeletons
of Miles and Edgar Rosyth, the deceased children
of Clara and Henry.
They are located inside of the nursery, which
is inaccessible to outsiders, with a door
that seems able to seal itself shut at will
and keep researchers out.
The two skeletons are largely inactive, remaining
on the floor of the nursery in the fetal position
at nearly all times.
They only become active during periods of
extreme activity from the Clara entity.
When Clara is especially active, and attempting
to leave her usual domain in the house’s
tower, the skeletons have been reported to
wrestle and play with each other, dance around
the room, or stand at the door to the nursery,
appearing to be waiting for something.
On one notable occasion though, on June 12th,
1990, both instances of SCP-2696-2 were able
to actually leave the nursery and travel elsewhere
in the house.
A series of massive lightning strikes raised
the energy levels in the house, and Clara’s
radiation levels suddenly spiked significantly.
Surge protectors placed in the house failed,
and Clara became more active than usual, transforming
into a swirling dark mass that emitted an
ear splitting shriek.
The front door of the mansion slammed itself
shut and refused to open, trapping the research
team who were present at the time.
They were only able to exit after SCP-2696-2A
and 2B were spotted leaving the nursery.
Hand in hand, they approached Clara and opened
their arms to her.
Pacified, perhaps by some distant echo of
a mother’s love, the entity quieted, and
the Foundation team was finally able to leave.
It is still unknown how 2A and 2B were able
to leave the nursery, but there have not been
any incidents of this level since.
Currently, the Dark Peak mansion remains standing,
and is largely untouched from how its creator
left it.
The SCP Foundation maintains a strict perimeter
of one square kilometer around the house,
and no civilians are permitted to cross it.
Not only is the building restricted for civilians,
most SCP Foundation personnel are also forbidden
from entering the house.
Some of the only ones who are allowed inside
are a special class of SCP Foundation personnel,
Experimental Containment Research Group, or
ECRG, and MTF Theta-77, nicknamed "Who You
Gonna Call?"
Given what was learned in the 1990 activation
event, it is apparent that the containment
procedures have a rate of failure that does
not adequately contain SCP-2696-1, and according
to the containment file, there is a 47% chance
of Clara breaching containment completely
by 2030.
Catherine Steadman once wrote: “Houses aren’t
haunted, people are.”
Henry Rosyth was so haunted by the loss of
his beloved wife and children that he could
not stand to live in his big empty house all
alone.
Henry Rosyth may be long gone, but his attempts
to grasp at that which was long gone before
him have forever changed the house he built.
His grief, his pain, his energy, filled the
house with echoes of his loved ones, and,
as pain often does when left untreated, it
began to fester and turn foul.
Dr. Henry Rosyth was a deeply haunted man,
and now his haunted house is all that remains
of him.
Now go check out “SCP-1730 - What Happened
to Site-13?
The Full Story Compilation” and “SCP-1337
- The Hitchhiker” for anomalies that’ll
chill you to the bone!